This lecture is a summary of this
course.
This map shows the major topics we have
covered in this course.
And here are some key high level
takeaway messages.
First we talked about the natural
language content analysis.
Here the main takeaway message is natural
language processing is the foundation for
text retrieval.
But current NLP isn't robust
enough, so the bag of words
representation is generally the main
method used in modern search engines.
And it's often sufficient for the most
of the search tasks, but obviously for
more complex such tasks than we need a
deeper natural language processing
techniques.
And we then talked about the high level
strategies for text access and we
talked about the push vs pull. In pull,
we talked about the querying versus
browsing.
In general, in future search engines we
should integrate all these techniques
to provide multiple information access.
And then we talked about a number of
issues related to search engines
we talked about the search problem,
and we framed that as a ranking
problem.
And we talked about a number of
retrieval methods.
We started with the overview of vector
space model and the probabilistic
model, and then we talked about the
vector Space Model in depth.
and we also later talked about the language
modeling approaches, and that's
a probabilistic model and here
The main takeaway messages is that modern
retrieval functions tend to look
similar, and they generally use various
heuristics.
Most important ones are TF-IDF
weighting, document length normalization,
and TF is often transformed through
a sublinear
Transformation function.
And then we talked about how to
implement a retrieval system.
And here the main techniques that we
talked about are how to construct the
inverted index so that we can prepare
the system to answer query quickly.
And we talked about how to perform search
by using the inverted index.
And we then talked about how to evaluate
the text retrieval system.
Mainly introduced the Cranefield
evaluation methodology.
This is a very important evaluation
methodology that can be applied to many
tasks.
We talked about the major evaluation
measures, so the most important
measures for search engine--map(mean
average precision),  nDCG(normalized,
discounted cumulative gain), an also
precision and recall are
the two basic measures.
And we then talked about the feedback
techniques and we talked about the Rocchio
in the vector space model and the
mixture model in the language modeling
approach.
Feedback is a very important
technique, especially considering
the opportunity of learning from a lot
of clickthroughs on the web.
We then talked about Web search, and
here we talked about how to use
parallel indexing to solve the
scalability issue.
In indexing we introduce the map reduce
and then we talked about how to use
linking information on the web to
improve search.
We talked about page rank and HITS as
the major algorithms to analyze links
on the web.
We then talked about learning to rank.
This is the use of machine learning to
combine multiple features for improving
scoring not only the effectiveness can
be improved using this approach, but we
can also improve the robustness of the
ranking function so that it's not easy
to spam the search engine with just.
Some features
to promote a page.
And finally, we talked about the future
of web search.
We talked about some major directions
that we might see in the future in
improving the current generation of
search engines.
And then finally we talked about the
recommender systems and these are
systems to implement the push mode and
we talked about the two approaches.
One is content based, one is
collaborative filtering and they can be
combined together.
Now.
An obvious missing piece in this
picture is the user, you can see, so user
interface is also an important component
in any search engine, even though the
current searching interface is relatively
simple, they actually have been a lot
of studies of user interface related
to visualization for example.
And this is a topic that you can learn
more by reading this book.
It's an excellent book about all kinds of
studies of search interface.
If you want to know more about the
topics that we talked about, you can
also read some additional readings that
are listed here in this short course.
We only managed to cover some basic
topics in text retrieval and search
engines.
And these resources provide additional
information about the more advanced
topics, and they gave a more thorough
treatment of some of the topics that we
talked about and a main source is
synthesis digital library.
Where you can see a lot of short
textbook or textbooks or long
tutorials, they tend to provide a lot
of information to explain a topic and
there are multiple serieses that are
related to this course, and one is the information
concepts retrieval and services and
another is
Human language technology and yet
another is artificial intelligence and
machine learning.
There were also some major journals
and conferences listed here that tend
to have a lot of research papers
related to the topic of this course,
and finally, For more information about
resources, including readings and
toolkits, etc.
You can check out this URL.
So if you have not taken the text
mining course in this data mining
specialization series, then naturally
the next step is to take that course as
this picture shows to mine big text
data we generally need
two kinds of techniques, one is text
retrieval, which is covered in this
course and these techniques would help
us convert the raw big text data into
small relevant text data which are
actually needed in the specific
application.
Human plays an important role in mining
any text data becausw text data is
written for humans to consume, so
involving humans in the process of data
mining is very important.
And in this course we have covered
various strategies to help users get
access to the most relevant data.
These techniques are also essential in any
text mining system to help provide
provenance, stand to help users
interpret in the patterns that user would
find through text data mining.
So in general the user would have to go
back to the original data to better
understand the patterns.
So the text mining course, or rather
text mining analytics course will be
dealing with what to do once the user
has found the information.
So this is the second step in this
picture where we would convert the text
data into actionable knowledge.
And this has to do with helping users
to further digest the found
information or to find the patterns and
to reveal knowledge buried in text and
such knowledge can then be used in
application system to help decision
making or to help user finish a task.
So if you have not taken that course,
the natural step in the natural next
step would be to take that course.
Thank you for taking this course.
I hope you have found this course to be
useful to you and I look forward to
interacting with you at a future
opportunity.